أكد نشر الملاحة أن
المظلة قد تم نشرها ونحن نشهد
تباطؤًا كبيرًا
في السرعة الحالية لدينا وهي
450 مترًا في الثانية
للدرع الحراري ، وقد تباطأ تقدم الضغط الآن
إلى سرعات دون سرعة الصوت وتم فصل الدرع الحراري
مما يسمح لكل من الرادار
والكاميرات لإلقاء نظرة أولى على
سرعة التيار السطحي هي 145 مترًا في
الثانية وعلى ارتفاع حوالي
10 كيلومترات وتسعة كيلومترات ونصف
فوق السطح
الآن مرشح تقارب حل السرعة
3.3 مترًا في الثانية
ارتفاع 7.4 كيلومترات الآن
قفل الرادار قيد التشغيل  تبلغ
سرعة التيار الأرضي حوالي 100 متر في
الثانية ،
ويستمر 6.6 كيلومتر من مثابرة السطح في النزول
على المظلة التي
نصل إليها عند تهيئة
الملاحة النسبية للتضاريس
، وبالتالي تحضير
محركات الهبوط ، تبلغ سرعتنا الحالية
حوالي 90 مترًا لكل  الثانية على
ارتفاع 4.2
كيلومترات
صالحة لدينا تأكيد ذلك
لقد أنتج نظام رؤية المسبار
حلاً صالحًا
وجزءًا من تناغم الملاحة النسبية للتضاريس ،
فلدينا توقيت لمحركات الهبوط
الخلفية ، حيث تبلغ سرعة ضبط السرعة الحالية 83
مترًا في الثانية عند حوالي 2.6
كيلومترًا من السطح إلى المريخ ،
ولدينا تأكيد بأن الغلاف الخلفي
لديه  نحن نفصل حاليًا
عن
السرعة الحالية لمناورة التحويل تبلغ حوالي 75 مترًا في
الثانية على
ارتفاع حوالي كيلومتر واحد من سطح
المريخ
هنا في برافو الآمن ، لقد
أكملنا التضاريس النسبية
الحالية لسرعة الملاحة الحالية حوالي
30 مترًا في الثانية ارتفاع حوالي
على بعد 300 متر
من سطح المريخ
، بدأنا الأكورديون بسرعة ثابتة ،
مما يعني أننا
نجري رافعة السماء على وشك
إجراء مناورة flyclean للقطارات المعلقة
على بعد
حوالي 20 مترًا من السطح ، وقد
حصلنا على إشارات من
mro tango delta touchdown.